the details that I'm about to share with
you in this video are so fascinating
that it's gonna make you rethink
everything you thought you knew about
the Sahara Desert and our lost ancient
past because when we think of the Sahara
Desert we picture an endless sea of sand
dunes that stretch further than the eye
can see
located of course in the middle of a
blistering hot desert that is larger
than the entire continental United
States but what we're just now learning
is that the world's largest nonpolar
desert is actually the widespread burial
grounds of countless mysteriously
unknown ancient ruins and civilizations
that have long since been forgotten
having been consumed and hidden by the
sands of time thousands of years ago and
here's the thing when I say thousands of
years ago that's the part where things
start to get really strange because it
turns out that the most recent
scientific evidence shows that the
Sahara Desert is far younger than we
ever thought in fact what scientists
assumed was millions of years old we now
know that as recently is just five
thousand years ago the Sahara Desert was
a lush green tropical paradise that
spanned from Egypt to the Atlantic coast
of the Western Sahara and contained the
world's largest freshwater lakes ever
known to have existed and not only that
a massive network of rivers that made
this entire region an oasis for ancient
human civilizations thus explaining why
in just the last few years we've been
finding so many mysteriously unknown
structures and what is now a remote
barren wasteland and listen to this
scientists that analyzed this recent
data concluded that in as little as just
100 years the lush green tropical
paradise that spanned thousands of miles
across North Africa was mysteriously
wiped out and transformed into what is
now the world's largest hot desert think
about that and as little as 100 years
one century in other words something
unbelievably radical happened here on
earth and the not
distant past to cause a complete
swinging climate throughout such an
enormous region and so quickly although
I must say that estimates do vary with
some scientists saying that it was more
likely to be over the course of five
centuries rather than one century but
either way we are talking about an
unbelievably short period of time so the
big question becomes why did this happen
well scientists from MIT believe that
this shift in climate is related to a
20,000 year cycle and changes to the
Earth's orbital tilt thus causing most
of the Sahara to go back and forth from
a desert to a jungle over and over again
with the last shift occurring somewhere
around 5,000 years ago now keep in mind
that estimates vary on this as well with
some specifically stating 5,000 years
ago
others stating 6000 years ago and
there's even more broad estimates
stating between 4,500 and 8,000 years
ago with others even stating dates as
far back as 10,000 and 11,000 years ago
which to me just goes to show how little
we including scientists actually know
much of what we have are guesses
but I do find the estimates of 11,000
years ago to be quite interesting as it
just so happens to be very close to the
Younger driest climate catastrophe that
was right in that time frame I can't
help but wonder if this is related in
some way and you know that reminds me
does this give any credence to the
declassified documents that I discussed
in a recent video where it was stated
that the Earth's poles rapidly shift and
are followed by an immediate reversal
every 6500 years I mean really why on
earth was the CIA discussing this book
in a meeting and why did they classify
the notes from that meeting now whether
or not the information discussed in
those documents is true whatever it was
that happened on earth in that period of
time to rapidly turn the Sahara into a
massive desert from what was a lush
tropical environment well there's no
doubt that the abrupt changes would have
meant disaster to wildlife vegetation
and of course the civilizations that
occupied the Sahara at that time and
when we consider the Sahara Desert
geographical location to Egypt or should
I say the fact that Egypt is within the
Sahara Desert and combining the fact
that the land of ancient Egypt is
without a doubt the largest
concentration of ancient ruins and
artifacts found anywhere on earth and
that it just so happens to date back to
the same period of time is when the
Sahara was green for example it has long
been said the Egypt's first dynasty
dates back to just over five thousand
years ago and the alleged first Egyptian
pyramid is estimated to have been
constructed around that time as well or
at least within the timeframe of when
the Sahara was said to be green so hold
that thought and consider the awkward
fact that I've mentioned in numerous
past videos which is that the Great
Sphinx of Giza has massive amounts of
rain water erosion within its enclosure
and I say awkward because the experts
have always claimed that the Sphinx must
be around 4,500 years old yet recent
geological analysis implies that this
cannot be the case as the last time the
Nile Delta region had significant
rainfall was more than seven thousand
years ago right in the timeframe of when
the Sahara was Green and had ten times
the rainfall that it does today in other
words the scientific data overwhelmingly
suggests that the Sphinx is at least
double the age of what we were taught in
school which of course only further adds
to the mystery of ancient Egypt itself
but think about what all of this means
the ancient ruins and relics that have
been found from the Egyptians is
concentrated largely around the Nile
River and this makes total sense as
civilizations exist where there's water
so combine that with the timeframe
estimates of when the Sahara went from a
lush green tropical paradise to a
massive barren desert several thousand
years ago well there's obviously a
connection here and going back to what I
just pointed out regarding the ancient
Egyptians developing their civilization
along the Nile River and while taking
into account that the Sahara Desert was
actually a hospitable environment made
up of rivers and lakes at that same
period of time we should ask ourselves
if the old legends stating that the Nile
River once ran from west to east have
merits I mean could this be true because
let's not forget what Herodotus
the so-called father of history had
written and described in his literature
at the time of 450 BC which others later
went on to create into a map after his
death and this map annotates what
Herodotus described that the Nile River
went west to east right through the
Sahara as it eventually curved north and
went right up through the Nile Delta
notice how it originates in the Western
Sahara though approximately in the land
of what is now modern-day Mauritania
which just so happens to be the same
geographical location of a massive
network of ancient dried-up rivers that
were discovered by scientists in 2015
and do you want to guess the timeframe
of when they believed these rivers last
existed 5,000 years ago what a
coincidence as this finding was
completely separate from the studies
that declared that the Sahara Desert was
Green as recently as 5000 years ago
which by the way the newly discovered
rivers were not exclusive to just
Mauritania have they have been found
throughout the Sahara in fact at least
three different networks of rivers have
been identified so far and they all
happen to date back to approximately
5000 years ago it's pretty remarkable
that separate teams of scientists and
researchers working in different parts
of the world found several different
lines of evidence to come to these
conclusions conclusions that just so
happened to match each other so
precisely and the implications of this
are enormous because undoubtedly ancient
humans would have lived and migrated
along these networks of rivers that
enveloped much of the Sahara just as
ancient Egyptians did so along the Nile
River and look at what I found while
researching this a study that flat-out
corroborates how ancient rivers in the
Sahara would have likely supported human
migration routes it seems to me that
these areas around the rivers need to be
excavated now take a look at this
illustration of the network of rivers
identified so far and notice how it
compares to Herodotus map which shows
the Nile going east southeast before it
erupted Lee curves to the north
I find the similarity very interesting
leave a comment and share what your
thoughts are on all of this and see if
you see the comparison as well but
real quick you'll likely remember me
citing her Adonis's map last year in my
third video on Atlantis and the recut
structure as he had written and
described the capital of Atlantis being
located south of the Outlets mountains
in the Western Sahara and later in this
video I'm going to share something very
interesting with you that involves the
Sahara Desert and the Recon structure
but the point right now is that the
latest scientific evidence shows us that
a massive network of rivers traveled
through the Sahara before whatever it
was it happened to turn it into a desert
where it was then consumed with sand and
long-forgotten not to be discovered
until at least 5,000 years later and
speaking of being consumed with sand
here's something interesting to think
about which is the condition that Egypt
was initially found when it was surveyed
by outsiders in more modern times most
of it was completely buried in sand for
thousands of years it's almost as if the
actual people who created these
mind-boggling structures were wiped out
and erased from memory before others
eventually arrived and made it their
home I mean let's not forget that not
one single hieroglyph or petroglyph
shows anything about the pyramids
literally nothing not one single one why
is that what's that about I mean hell
let's not forget the awkward fact that
the modern language of in Egypt is not
even close to the same language that the
dynastic Egyptians spoke and we have
only made any sense of Egyptian
hieroglyphs because of the rosetta stone
just think about that could this be
further evidence that two completely
different civilizations live there
thousands of years apart perhaps
separated in time following the collapse
of the green Sahara
I mean clearly something occurred in
Egypt to erase so much and create the
incredibly mysterious nature of this
lost civilization that we debate so much
about today much of which was somehow
destroyed massive statues toppled over
and not only that what on earth
destroyed certain pyramids there is more
than one like this an unexplained
mystery that very few people are even
aware of and I say mystery because no I
do not believe that a bunch of angry
people with copper sledgehammers did
this not
a second however that's a topic for
another video that I'll certainly make
but getting back on the topic of the
green Sahara it probably would have
looked more like the Amazon than the
desert that we see today we really need
to use our imaginations to wrap our
heads around how different this area
would have looked at that point in time
and what would that have meant for
ancient human civilizations living there
and besides the vast network of rivers I
haven't even discussed the ancient
dried-up lakes that were in the Sahara
at the same period of time as those
rivers one of which is said to have been
the largest freshwater lake ever known
to have existed ancient lake chad which
at one point covered nearly 140,000
square miles of surface coverage or more
than 360 thousand square kilometers to
put that into perspective all of the
North American Great Lakes combined make
up just over ninety four thousand square
miles or 240,000 square kilometers
simply mind-boggling and there were
other massive lakes there as well one of
which when at its highest level covered
more than 42,000 square miles or more
than 108 thousand square kilometers and
it wasn't even discovered until later in
2010 but go figure because look at what
it looks like today you would never know
that anything was there at all
it's amazing how wind sand and heat as a
way of erasing everything even over just
five thousand years take a look at this
illustration which shows the known
locations of siharan lakes that existed
between 9,000 years ago and present-day
they were all over the Sahara and guess
what
these massive Sahara Lakes are all said
to have dried up approximately 5,000
years ago the same estimated period of
time as the network of rivers and keep
in mind that the discovery of these
lakes were separate from the discovery
of the rivers identified years apart by
totally different scientists and
researchers so in other words the Sahara
Desert was a freakin paradise just a few
thousand years ago and what makes it
even more interesting is that we're just
now starting to figure this out which
means that there are incredible
discoveries waiting to be found
throughout this massive region this is
just the beginning of what has the
potential
to be the greatest archaeological
discoveries ever found I mean the Sahara
may very well be the ancient jackpot
especially when you consider its
proximity to ancient Egypt because the
discoveries are already happening
despite the fact that most of the Sahara
is one of the least studied
archaeological places on earth the
discoveries are now increasing in
frequency thanks of course to the modern
technology being utilized on drones and
satellites they're even referring to it
as archaeology from space
the high altitude and space borne radar
technology is allowing scientists to
conduct ground-penetrating radar that
penetrates up to a few meters deep and
actually that was what they were capable
of back in the mid 1990s so I have a
feeling that the technology has
developed significantly since then think
about that
but thanks to this technology over just
the past few years discoveries have been
found in countries ranging from Libya
all the way over to the Western Sahara
and keep in mind that Libya neighbours
Egypt directly to the west literally
sharing the same desert and in the
middle of the Libyan desert they've
discovered castle-like fortresses that
shocked archaeologists as of course
nobody thought anyone had ever lived
there but what they found were walls 13
feet or 4 meters high and even
sophisticated irrigation systems they're
even starting to find mysterious ruins
as far away as the Western Sahara
although they may not look impressive
hundreds of the stone structures have
been found so far and what's interesting
is the remote location of these findings
and the fact that nobody knows who made
them or when and they're also at surface
level so the question becomes what else
could be buried and waiting to be
unearthed in this area and there are
other ancient ruins scattered throughout
the Sahara from Algeria to Chad some of
these ruins are of course credited to
the Romans which I do not disagree with
however the question I have is what are
we not seeing that's buried beneath all
this sand and where these structures
built on top of older ancient structures
which is something commonly seen
throughout the world but even if these
structures are all at surface level you
may not even know about it anyway I mean
most people have
no idea that there are sophisticated
ancient ruins in Sudan including
pyramids and this not forget the Sudan
borders Egypt directly to the south is
there a connection here and you know
when you consider the incredible size of
the Sahara which spans three and a half
million square miles or nine million
square kilometres and is more than three
thousand miles across from one coast to
the other as it stretches from the
Atlantic Ocean to the Red Sea and
although most of the deserts is not
actually covered in massive sand dunes
the parks there are are as deep as 100
to 141 feet in depth and make no mistake
some of the greatest discoveries from
her ancient past may very well be
waiting to be exhumed under dunes just
like these I mean this area is so big
that it literally affects weather
systems around the world
for instance winds from the Sahara
created a heat wave in Britain just this
summer and not only that the sands of
the Sahara were carried all the way over
to Houston Texas word affected the color
of the sky making it yellow and this
storm did more than increase the
temperatures in Britain and turned the
sky yellow in Texas because it even
delayed the hurricane season in the
Atlantic and Caribbean as well I mean
come on that is absolutely incredible
but there's more the sands of the Sahara
Desert even fertilized the Amazon
rainforest every year millions of tons
of dust containing rich nutrients
including tens of thousands of tons of
phosphorus is carried across the
Atlantic Ocean and end up fertilizing
the soils of South America
I mean Wow right it truly is incredible
to think that this region is affecting
weather and ecosystems around the world
but I suppose it makes sense it just
simply never occurred to me until I
started researching this topic but
here's something else that's really
interesting to think about so humans are
said to have originated in Africa right
so how do we know that there's not areas
of Africa aside from the Sahara Desert
that have ancient ruins waiting to be
discovered for example in the Congo
jungle and rainforest remember what I
shared in my previous video involving
airborne lidar conducting 3d mapping of
the Guatemalan jungle which identified
tens of thousands of buried Mayan ruins
that
scientists discovered just last year
areas of this dense jungle that had
already been surveyed on foot were
unable to see any of these remnants as
they had been consumed by the earth and
jungle in less than 1,200 years which is
unbelievably quick I mean even consumed
a seven-story pyramid that they
literally walked right by during
previous survey mapping while on foot
and this is only what they found so far
there are vast areas of jungle in
Central and South America that have not
been scanned in fact only an incredibly
small portion had been scanned in
comparison to what's left so is it
possible that there are other
discoveries waiting to be made that are
buried in jungles such as Central Africa
where literally nobody is looking and
never have just something to think about
now I mentioned early in this video that
I want to discuss some details involving
the Sahara Desert and the recon
structure as it pertains to the lost
city of Atlantis in my prior videos I
suggested that North Africa appears to
have been obliterated with tidal forces
that may have originated from the
Mediterranean Sea and flowed through the
rakaat structure in Mauritania which
could have been what caused Atlantis's
destruction and that's assuming that
this was Atlantis as the legend states
that it was consumed and fell into the
depths of the sea and by simply looking
at satellite imagery it's not hard to
see the evidence of vast water erosion
well listen to this in just the past few
weeks a shocking discovery was made that
was based on a 20-year study conducted
by scientists and researchers that
proved that the ocean literally ran
right through the heart of North Africa
at one point in the past allegedly tens
of millions of years ago and they're
calling it the trans-saharan Seaway and
the implications of this are absolutely
astounding
just look at where it originates in
North Africa and snakes its way through
the Sahara through the same location
that I suggested in my prior video and
we now know that yes this area that
looks like water flowed right through it
actually did now of course this map does
not show it going west through the
structure but if you simply go to Google
Earth and view and play around with the
elevations above sea level in all these
outlined areas you'll quickly find that
the path through the Recon structure is
at the same elevations as the
trans-saharan Seaway again look at this
and tell me that tidal forces didn't
flow right through here and in fact
people that have recently visited the
recod on foot observed that the
structure is right down to bedrock just
as you'd expect if the freaking ocean
had blasted right through it but what is
left are massive salt deposits at
surface level in and around the recut
structure I did not include this
significant detail in my prior videos
because I wasn't positive on it at the
time but it yes it has since been
confirmed without a doubt the ocean was
once here so the question becomes when
and although there is of course doubt as
to whether the Ricoh structure could be
the location of velocity of Atlantis but
I've since dug deeper and I've come
across new information much of which is
unbelievably fascinating and a few
details that virtually nobody knows
about information that will make even
the skeptics of this location second
guess in question what might be possible
but I'll stop myself there because there
is a lot more to share a lot more and
it's certainly debatable
so I'll have to make another video on
the topic of the recut structure in
Atlantis so look forward to that soon
and I'll also be making another video on
Atlantis involving other possible
locations such as Santorini and the
Azores Islands and other places so look
forward to that but the topic of
Atlantis aside what on earth is waiting
to be discovered underneath the sands of
the Sahara I mean mark my words I'm
telling you in our lifetimes there's
gonna be some massive discoveries
they're gonna happen in the Sahara that
are gonna blow our minds because if all
of the Sahara a thousands of miles
across was green tropical vegetated with
rivers and lakes and humans originated
from Africa you can bet that people were
living there so the question becomes
what's there waiting to be found
but anyways I'll close this up here this
is getting long but I'm Jimmy this is
bright insight hit the like button and
subscribe and leave a comment and let me
know what your thoughts are on all of
this and everything that I discuss in
the video and without a doubt
there are other places around the world
that are very likely to have an
abundance of unknown inch true uns
waiting to be discovered such as Central
America South America and other places
too so anyways guys I'll leave it at
that take care and look forward to
another video coming real soon bye
everybody